- This episode of LegalEagle was
made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer for free
for two month by clicking
the link in the description.
Okay, I'll admit it,
I was pleasantly surprised
by "The Witcher".
Interesting characters,
compelling narratives
and new takes on an old genre.
But then I got to this part.
- Lioness of Cintra!
I come to claim what is rightfully mine.
Pavetta, by the law of surprise.
(gasps)
- Oh.
Cool, the law of surprise.
That thing.
Wait, the what now?
And then a number of thoughts
went through my head.
Okay, Devin, you went to law school.
This is clearly a law, this is a thing.
You know this, think Devin, law school.
Contracts, offer,
acceptance, law of surprise?
Think!
You don't want Thomas Frank
to be make fun of you again.
Wait, there's no such thing
as the law of surprise!
Is there?
(bleep)
It was an emotional couple of moments.
(joyful music)
Hey LegalEagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer,
because I'm trying to
figure out "The Witcher",
and if I have to do it then,
by God, I'm taking you with me.
"The Witcher" is the newest
entree into the fantasy genre,
an eight-episode series on Netflix
for those who are still going
through "Game of Thrones" withdrawal.
The show is based on a set
of short stories published
by Polish author, Andrzej Sapkowski,
and also gave rise to the
famous "Witcher" videogames as well.
The main plot centers around
a few main characters.
The central protagonist, Geralt of Rivia,
the eponymous witcher.
The mage, Yennefer of Vengerberg
and Princess Cirilla.
Their lives are intertwined
for a variety of reasons,
most of which are tied
to the vague concept of destiny.
- Destiny has determined
the surprise be Pavetta.
- If you're unfamiliar with the books,
then the show itself can
be a little bit confusing,
based on the different roles,
between the witcher, elves, mages,
and there's a lot to
absorb and understand.
But, possibly none are more
confusing and controversial
than "The Witcher"'s law of surprise.
The law of surprise is introduced
in episode four of "The Witcher",
when during a soiree...
Also, they refer to this
party as a soiree many times
and this french neologism
seems way out of place.
At any rate, during this
soiree, the point is
to find a suitor for Queen
Calanthe's daughter, Pavetta.
And during the course
of these suitors trying
to woo Pavetta, a helmeted
man, Duny, comes in claiming
that the queen's daughter is
actually owed to him, due to his right
under the law of surprise.
- I am Lord Urcheon of Erlenwald
and I have come to claim your
daughter's hand in marriage.
- He claims to have earned
this right by saving the life
of the queen's late husband, King Roegner.
- My whole life, a living
misery, until the day
that I saved your husband, King Roegner,
from a certain death.
By tradition, I chose the
law of surprise as payment.
- Duny, or the knight of
Urcheon, demands his payment
in the form of Pavetta's hand in marriage.
- Duny!
(Duny gasps)
- But don't worry, this isn't rapey,
because they conveniently already met
and fell in love off-screen,
in Canada probably.
So, Pavetta is what lawyers would call
his chattel property.
- Until destiny intervened
and our hearts collided.
- But also, girl power.
I guess.
So, despite the Me Too issues
with the law of surprise,
on it's face, the law is
relatively straightforward.
For payment of a great deed,
usually saving someone's
life, one can claim something
which the debtor does not yet possess
at the moment the law is claimed.
It's a surprise for the
giver and the receiver.
The tricky part is,
there appears to be two possible outcomes.
For the one invoking the law of surprise,
they will receive either the first thing
that comes to greet the indebted
when they return home after
their life is being saved
or what you find at home
and you don't expect.
Geralt, is apparently super cool
with this arranged marriage
slash indentured servitude
and when given the chance to repay Duny,
for saving his life, he
claims the same right
regarding Pavetta, and thus
the circle of slavery continues
with Pavetta's child, Ciri,
being contracted to Geralt.
- People linked by destiny
will always find each other.
- Feminism.
(Calanthe groans)
(heavy thud)
So, those are the terms
of the law of surprise,
but is it legal?
Let's take a look at
the legal enforceability
of the law of surprise
as if it were applied today in the,
usually non fantasy, world the we live in.
Now, right of the bat,
we can see that there's a huge problem
when dealing with any law
that allows one to acquire another person
as a designated method of payment.
As you probably know, the
Thirteenth Amendment states,
"Neither slavery nor
involuntary servitude,
"except as punishment
"for crime whereof the
party shall have been
"duly convicted, shall exist
within the United States,
"or any subject to their jurisdiction."
So, considering in both
instances that we see on screen
in "The Witcher", the law
of surprise is invoked
to claim the daughter
of one who was saved,
it appears that this would
clearly be a violation
of the Thirteenth Amendment
against involuntary servitude.
Now, sure, Pavetta
seemed perfectly content
with being given over to Duny,
since they had already fallen in love...
conveniently.
But, I've got to imagine that
that's more of the exception,
rather than the rule.
Clearly, the witcher has no problem
with involuntary servitude.
- A promise made must be honored.
- But Bill of Rights, shmill of rights!
Let's think beyond the Constitution.
What if we assume that the law of surprise
resulted in the transfer
of something other
than humans, maybe a new puppy.
"A pup", as Eist refers to it.
Or a new car that your significant other
brought for you while you were away.
Would the law of surprise be legal then?
Well, to answer this
question it would require
a foray into the complicated
world of contract law.
And just as the delightful Jaskier says...
- Respect doesn't make history.
- Well, contract law probably doesn't make
for great fantasy fiction,
but let's take a look
and see how we might make a workable
law of surprise in real life.
Now, by way of background, contract law,
unlike some other areas
of law, like criminal law,
is not really codified into a bunch of
neatly packaged statutes.
Contract law is primarily
developed from the common law.
- 'Tis no swindle.
Asking for payment with
the law of surprise
is as old as mankind itself.
- Generally contract law is a blend of
state case law that's developed by judges,
and statutes that are
passed by state legislators.
So, first things first,
how is a contract formed?
Well, in order for
there for be a contract,
there's certain requirements or elements
that have to be met, and while it varies
a little bit from state to state,
generally those are: an offer,
an acceptance of that offer,
consideration between the parties,
mutuality of obligation,
competency and capacity,
and in certain circumstances,
though certainly not all
or even most circumstances,
a written instrument, a written contract.
So, let's begin with the offer.
An offer, for purposes of contract law,
is a promise to do or refrain from doing
something specific in the future.
An offer can be a simple
as, party A offers
to mow party B's lawn next Tuesday.
So, in the case of "The Witcher",
right off the bat, it's hard to see how
the law of surprise even meets the first
element of contract formation,
in that it doesn't contain a valid offer.
It's more like a gratuitous gift.
Essentially, half of the
exchange is already accomplished.
For example, King Roegner's life has
already been saved by Duny,
so that there's no reason for a
contract to be formed
in order for payment,
because nothing was
offered in the first place.
Now, on the other hand,
just because the parties
don't expressly exchange words,
it's still possible that based
on their actions something,
known as an implied-in-fact
contract, has occurred.
An implied-in-fact
contract is an obligation
arising from a mutual agreement
and intent to promise,
where the agreement and the
promise haven't actually
been expressed in words.
Now, regardless of the means of
expressing the contract,
an implied-in-fact contract
still requires an unambiguous offer,
acceptance and mutual intent to be bound,
and of course, consideration.
But, here we run into the same problems.
The deed has already been done,
the life has been saved
under circumstances
that don't give rise to a contract
or an implied contract, so we
still have the same problems.
But for the sake of
argument, let's consider
the fact that we're calling
this the law of surprise.
So, in this fictional scenario,
the law of surprise was passed by
a governing body and
codified into a statute,
and thus no offer or
acceptance is required,
merely a life being saved
requires payment in return.
So, for the sake of argument,
let's assume that the, I don't know,
legislator or parliament of Cintra,
has passed this law of surprise
and it doesn't require offer or acceptance
in terms of these circumstances,
where you save a life.
Let's move on to the third element
that's required for a
contract to be formed,
and that's consideration.
And consideration is
generally described as
promising something of value in exchange
for a specified action or
non-action of another person.
Essentially, value for value.
So, if you agree to
give a gift to someone,
that's not a contract, because you have
gratuitously offered something to them
and received no consideration
back for your promise.
And if that's the case,
that might actually work.
You obviously have performed
something of great value,
you saved someone's life,
and that is extremely valuable
to the person whose life was saved,
and in return you're being
promised this other thing.
You don't know what it is,
but it might be something of great value,
and the law allows for you to contract for
something as valueless as a,
they call it a peppercorn.
Yes, it's a very, very low value,
but it's value nonetheless and you are
allowed to contract based
on that mutual exchange.
So, this law of surpise
actually kinda works,
in terms of consideration,
but that raises another problem,
which is that often a
defense to a contract
is vagueness or ambiguity,
and here's where things
really start to get dicey.
Courts require what's called
a meeting of the minds,
to form a contract.
That means that the parties agree to what
the terms of the contract are,
and if we look back at the law of surprise
we see that the thing
that is being promised is
either the first thing that comes to greet
the debtor when they return home
after their life has been saved,
or what they find at
home and didn't expect.
So, in a word, that sounds ambiguous.
Now, on the other hand, every
contract involves some risk.
Let's say you formed a
contract with a farmer,
to buy their entire crop for the year.
You might get a huge bumper crop,
or you might get nothing, because the crop
was wiped out because of a drought.
So, there's always an inherent risk
and some ambiguity in
terms of performance,
but this also seems like you have no idea
what you're contracting
for in the first place.
On top of that, there's overall ambiguity
as to how this contract would be enforced.
Even the specific words
used in the law of surprise,
like greet, or the time frame that
we're talking about here could be open
to multiple interpretations.
What does it mean to be greeted with
something when you get home?
What if the first thing that happens
is your dog runs out and
licks you in the face?
What if your spouse is angry with you
and starts yelling at you?
What if there're multiple things
that are new that you didn't
expect when you got home?
What if there're twins?
Do you owe both of them?
Or just one?
The options and
interpretations are endless.
I feel like, at the very least,
everyone in this fictional
world of "The Witcher"
needs a good lawyer to talk about all
of these different eventualities.
And then, of course, we run
into huge performance issues.
In contract law,
generally your damages are
measured in money.
Sometimes you're entitled to what's
called specific performance,
or in other words compelling
one party to turn over the other.
For example, that happens
a lot in real estate,
where a piece of real estate is considered
so unique that money
damages are not enough
to compensate someone for
the loss of that property,
that was supposed to be turned over.
And if we are talking about money damages
for a person that was promised
and doesn't want to go through with
the indentured servitude,
how are we supposed to
value that person's life?
In daylights and sunsets?
In midnights or cups of coffee?
Basically impossible to
put a value on that person.
And there's at least one
other contract offense,
that would probably bar a
law of surprise contract
from being formed,
which is called the statute of frauds.
Now, I mentioned earlier
that most contracts
actually don't need to be written.
That is a common misconception.
You can have an oral contact,
as long as you meet the other requirements
for contract formation, but the law
requires that certain contracts do,
in fact, be written down.
The idea is that certain contracts
are so important, that to prevent fraud,
we need to require a written document.
Now, the types of contracts to which
this defense applies, are contracts often
that involve the sale or transfer of land,
contracts that cannot be
completed within one year,
and those made in
connection with marriage.
And two of those scenarios could be argued
by a defendant in challenging
the enforceability
of the law of surprise.
Certainly, the example of Duny and Pavetta
highlights both of these contract types.
Duny didn't claim the law of surprise
for Pavetta until 15 years after
the contract was made.
- I knew no woman would
ever accept it like this,
and so I waited.
I waited until the twelfth bell,
when the curse breaks.
- And on top of that,
Duny is claiming that
his contract entitles
him to marry Pavetta,
based on the law of surprise,
and thus, we have a legitimate defense,
that under the statute of frauds,
that this contract was
required to be in writing,
and it wasn't.
Now, is there any way that we could
revise this law of surprise,
in order to make a
legally binding contract?
Well, I think so, but there are a
couple of things that
we'd need to address.
First, we have the ambiguity problem,
so we need to get rid of this,
"You're entitled to whatever it is that
"the debtor finds upon returning home."
Instead of saying it's whatever they find,
at the time of contract formation you say,
"I want, in return for saving your life,
"this specific thing.
"Your new car.
"Your horse.
"Your newborn pup."
By specifying the things
that you are entitled to,
you remove a lot of the ambiguity.
On top of that, in order
to solve the problem
of offer and acceptance, instead of
claiming the law of
surprise after you save
someone's life, you might want to say
before you save their life,
"Yes, I will in fact save your life,
"but only if you promise me, X, Y or Z."
By proactively doing it,
in a sort of underhanded way,
they are promising to give you that thing,
in return for your consideration of
saving their life, obviously
something of great value.
And, of course, leave the women out of it.
You can't contract for people.
(gentle piano music)
Now, of course, this kind
of takes the surprise
out of the law of surprise,
but, I mean, I don't know
what you want from me.
No one ever spoke to their
lawyer, and was like,
"I love talking to my lawyer.
"They let me do whatever I want."
So yeah, the law of surprise,
as it's portrayed in "The Witcher",
has more legal holes in
it than Swiss cheese.
Certainly, if someone
brought a breach of contract
case based on the law of surprise,
the court would strike down that contract
as invalid on any number of grounds,
but based on some minor adjustments,
the law of surprise might
give rise to a valid contract.
But if we've learnt
anything from "The Witcher",
it's that we should appreciate those who
roam the land looking to
right wrongs and do justice,
and I think you know
who I'm talking about.
So, if you could...
Please...
♪ Toss a coin to your lawyer ♪
♪ Oh website of plenty ♪
♪ A friend of legality ♪
(laughs)
Now, I bet you didn't
think I played guitar,
and you're kind of right,
because I barely play guitar.
(guitar strumming)
I've been meaning to
brush up on my skills,
and I've been meaning to take
Mike Boyd's Skillshare class,
"Guitar Fundamentals: Learn
Quick with Mike Boyd."
In his class, Mike walks you through the
basics of learning to play guitar,
starting with the guitar anatomy,
leading all the way up to
playing your first two songs.
Even if you've never played
a guitar in your life,
Mike Boyd will show you
what you need to know.
Or, if you want to learn another skill,
check out Mike's other Skillshare course,
"How to Learn: Strategies for Starting,
"Practicing and Mastering the Skills
"You've Always Wanted",
which helps anyone learn something new,
reduce their likelihood of
quitting a new challenge,
or get good at something faster.
Skillshare is an online
learning community,
that has tens of thousands
of classes on everything,
like music, design,
technology and business.
It's great for anyone who
wants to learn guitar,
or basically any other
skill that you can think of.
A yearly membership is
less than $10 per month,
but the first 500 LegalEagles will get
two free months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below.
Plus, clicking on the link
really helps out the channel.
So, just click the link
in the description.
A free membership gives
you unlimited access
to must know topics, so you can improve
your skills and learn new things.
All free for two months.
- Your skills will be rewarded.
- So, do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other legal reactions,
including my take on "South
Park" and "The Simpsons",
and I promise it features none of
my singing or guitar playing.
And as always, I'll see you in court.
(guitar strumming)